wenn man bedenkt dass es in bayern
erleben und auf und untergeht sondern
über und über hinüber und herüber waren
wir zur bisschen unübersichtlich und um
klarheit in dieses thema zu bringen habe
ich mit der grünwald freitags kommen die
fachfrau für bairische sprache um
bayerische kultur mit claudia pichler
gesprochen schauen sie mal was claudia
folgende circuit im studio darüber
geriet man fahrt auf münchen auf oder
auch spanien unter oder was datei für
wurst oder man kann ja über und
überfahren
gibt es da irgendwelche regeln wo man es
anwendet und wo man weiß warum man es
anwendet
also impression gibt es erstmal ganz
frühes und begrifflichkeiten wo man so
sagt also mal fahren nicht einfach
irgendwo hieß und an fahren vielleicht
hinüber oder her über irgendwas ist
intersport rent der heute längst von der
oberpfalz kommst dann fast auf münchen
oder du kannst auf zwinger saison oder
von über land gefahren einmal auf
münchen
also diese richtungen seien eigentlich
eure dabei und kennt sogar von münchen
selber also dass du sagst du fast auf
pasing aussehen du warst du warst auf
gears hinaus nach schwabing auf und nach
hausen musste man überfahren also sonst
an sagen weil in münchen gibt es
obergrenzen und das ist die isa und da
geht es immer darum wer ist gesenkt und
wer es bringt also ist eine frage von
der perspektive und ich glaube das ist
eine frage von wertung dann also wenn du
erwähnt bis das hat mir das an die und
trennt das wort früher ist immer das war
auch haidhausen und dort wohne im bund
eher so dass schwer getan
dass wir uns gerne herrn aber hierfür in
die stadt gefahren in der rede auf
münchen auf was sie übrigens von münchen
nach ingolstadt ingolstadt
diese wissen sie jetzt gar nicht ehrlich
gesagt weil wir fahren wenn es geht an
ingolstadt vorbei
[Applaus]